Dann kommen wir vom Flug, richtig landig, zu der Landung ist wichtig, dass wir vorgängig
geflugt haben, was wir von der Landenvolte fliegen, das ist rechts oder links,
vor allem ist es wichtig, dass wir alle die gleichen Regeln befolgen.
Denn in den Bereich von Flug sind wir nicht weit weg vom Boden, das heisst, wir haben keine
Zeit mehr oder wenig Zeit zu reagieren.
Wir haben 1.000 m übergrund, wenn man abrückt, bis man nicht so macht, wie sehr der
Relief langsieht, zu reagieren und die Situation ist jetzt, beim Landen gut alles
schneller, weil der Boden einfach nöch ist.
Darum muss der Grundsatz sein, dass wir alle als die Landenvolte halten, und so
kann garantieren, dass man sieht, was der anderen vorgängig macht.
Die Landenvolte sieht so aus, dass wir uns von der Rängs oder rechtsvolten
entscheidet und nachher zu der Positionskreise, zu einer Abbaugkreise,
die wir uns in den Abbaugen, für eine super Landenvolte, zu beginnen.
Dort ist wichtig, dass wir in drei richtigen Kreisen, die man an die Landenvolte machen,
wenn man rechtsvolten, das sind es rechtskreis, wenn man linksvolten, das sind es linkskreis.
Dann gehen wir um eine höchige Landenvolte, die gesund ist.
Die gesundhöhe, das lehren wir in der E-Jetze, nach ein, zwei, drei Landigen,
wenn man gegen eine A-Flugflug hat, das kann variieren, je nach Luftmassen,
wo man euch befindet, muss das überhaupt nicht gleich sein,
sondern auch komplett, wenn der Wind im Spiel hat.
Darum wichtig ist, da ein Gespüri zu entwickeln und Vertrauen drauf.
Es hat noch jeden, zwei, drei, vier Flüge, die einen da brauchen wir,
aber darum sind eine Begleitung von Flugleeren mit dem Funke,
die ich schön angegeben habe, dass ich das sehr schnell fangstürme,
und nach Güssenarzt auf Flüge selbstständig machen kann.
Gegen A-Flug, Quere-A-Flug, an der Flug.
Wenn wir merken, den Gegen A-Flug, müssen wir deutlich zu Höch.
Da können wir wunderbar in Quere-A-Flug gehen
und der Quere-A-Flug können wir auch verlängern,
wenn wir Platz haben, weit, weit führen und den Bogen machen.
Wenn wir zu kurz sind, dann merken wir es nicht so viel,
ich kann es ganz einfach kürzen, wie es hier dargestellt ist.
Oder, wir könnten Quere-A-Flug auch mit S-X-Fach wiederholen
und S-Mand immer richtig Punkte folgen.
Und gute bei diesen S-Mandern können zu jedem Zeitpunkt
die Quere-A-Flug verloren und in A-Flug gehen wir, wenn wir es passt.
Nach A-Flug sind die gerade folgen.
Wir können selbstständige Liechten Korrektur machen,
wenn der Wind ein wenig sittlich kommt, aber schlussendlich wichtig,
Punkte zu erflügt.
Wenn wir merken, wir sind viel zu Höch,
gibt es verschiedene Varianten,
wir können z.B. uns groß machen.
Das heißt, der Pilot und dem Schirm macht relativ viel Widerstand
und ob wir hier banktacken,
dann gleiten wir gut, haben wir wenig Widerstand
oder wir machen uns grosser Sprichmissätze aus Aufengurzig,
schauen, dass uns das Fahrwerk nämlich beibereitsberat sind
und dann können wir viel Widerstand,
dann haben, haben wir ein schlechtes Geleiter.
Das spricht auch, wir können die Höhe effizient abbauern.
Und so kommen wir dann auf der Landepunkt zu.
Und die Variante wäre noch ganz leicht, die S-Flüge
ist auch erlaubt, oder wenn wir später dazukommen,
mit kleinen Örlilandern,
dass wir Dörrlinen nehmen, die Kleidschein mit einfach gesagt kleiner,
haben wir sie senken und auch so haben wir den besseren Volkschanzen
auf der Punkt zu landen.
Der Briefing über uns ist, dass im 30 Meter Kreis,
wo wir einen Treffen in Kreis innen treffen,
und dann haben wir die Landung super und gut bestanden.
Wichtig noch, wenn wir die Kleinen Oren machen müssen,
wenn du dich bewusst sind,
wir haben es so, dass wir nicht groß steuern können.
Ich kann mit Gewicht ausrichten,
aber eine Freensägeheit ist eingeschränkt,
dass wir das beachten tun.
Also lieber haben wir hier in die Zwiebeln,
dass etwas in der Unüberlegtsmache oder im Stress zu machen,
das ist meistens nicht gut.
Dann gibt es noch Situationen,
die wir in der Landung vielleicht etwas anders gekommen haben,
dass wir die Denkt haben.
Zum Beispiel sind wir Landenvolten angeflogen.
Wir haben vor oder Wintergelegter,
das ist immer schön so, dass wir mit einem anderen Fluggegen-Winnsetter
landen, wie wir sie normal machen.
Jetzt haben wir doch blöden, wie es plötzlich rückwinden will,
weil wir ihn einfach gewechselt haben.
Das ist kein Drama.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir die Landenvolten durchziehen,
wenn wir uns entschieden haben, die Landenvolten
und dann haben wir halt mit den Rückenwinlanden.
Mit den Rückenwinns heisst man mehr Geschwindigkeit im anderen Flug.
Das heisst, wir müssen einfach schneller,
effektive Türenbremsen,
als wir das beim normalen Landen gewöhnt sind.
Beim normalen Landen gehen wir in
gemietlich Türenbremsen bis uns das Friedland unten bleiben.
Und beim rückwinnden Landen müssen wir pizzerlich höchern
und wirklich entscheidend aber bremsen,
dass man das Momentum aufbaut,
wo das Schirm sich aufstellt und genau dann punkt und zipunkt und botter sind.
Selbst den kann man bei rückenwinnd schöne Landen machen, ausbeigend.
Fruckewinnden Landen ist also kein Drama, sondern auch ein Punkt,
wo man gut mal kann.
Ich bedanke natürlich nicht von 30 km im Rückenwinnd,
sondern von 5 bis 10 km im Winter,
wo man sitte Manager können.
Jetzt kann es ja auch sein, dass wir eine Handlandung mitmachen.
Das hat der Grund, dass er zum Beispiel ein Landenplatz gesperrt ist.
Wir haben keine andere Möglichkeit.
Die Handlandung ist wichtig, dass wir nicht richtig,
wenn wir dort die Hand haben, dass wir nicht auf der Hand zu fliegen.
Wir sind hier in der Handneigen, wo wir uns ein schlichter Dreckung machen,
beim Ausfleren, sondern mit dem Parallel zum Handlanden.
Da können wir genau gleiche Landen machen,
Parallel zum Hand aufsetzen.
Gut, das Dip-Dop.
Jetzt kann es ja auch sein, dass wir uns verschätzt haben.
Und wir haben jetzt den Landenplatz verpasst
und kommen auf einem Parkplatz, das Landen, die Auto steht.
Wie weg ist, es ist eine Unterschiede,
dass wir mit 30 km in der Zuhause fliegen,
dass wir nur mit 5 km, oder sogar 0 km,
können wir auch auf dem Zuhause landen.
Darum wäre die Kollision,
denken die Energie abzubauen und nicht einfach oben bleiben und schreien,
dann nichts.
Dann haben wir uns nicht mehr das Leute schauen,
dass wir noch mehr zuschauen haben in einer peinlichen Situation.
Wenn er aussehen kann, haben wir irgendetwas falsch gemacht,
den Landenplatz erreichen, den nicht mehr und auf dem Weg zum Landenplatz anziehen.
Dann ist ein Baumlandungsschicht,
sondern ich habe es vor irgendetwas richtig gefällt,
weil es dann noch einmal noch blöder ist zum Landen.
Ein Baumlandung, wenn es so könnte, bevorzugenäme den Notenbaum,
dann hätten es schön, ich könnte guter erst haben,
von der Abelampen und so wichtiges Schöner in der Flüge
auch da wieder Energie abbauen, durch Dürrebremse
und mit dem Kopf, mit der Koppgeschütze vor diesen Äst.
Wichtig, es gibt gute Dokumentationen über Baumrettungen.
Der gleiche Pilot, die beim Flug ist meistens sehr sicher,
wie ein sehr viel Leinen umgekommen.
Das gilt auch, wenn ein Notschirmabgang über einen Wald hättet,
da ist sehr viel Stoff, sehr viel Leinen um.
Und die verfangen sich in Äst, es ist selten oder kein sehr wenig gefällt,
wo der Pilot durch Bäume durch den Boden kommt,
meistens bleibt er hangen, und dann ist er grundsätzlich sicher.
Die meisten Umwelten, die durchaus aus der Resultierung sind,
weil die Leute im Schock kennen,
wenn meistens in Schock ganz klar ist, eine Notsituation,
wenn sich selbst besser reihen und dann abstürzen.
Weil es z.B. immer eine steile Gelände auf einem Baum besitzt
und die Leute, die so seitlich zum Gelände haben,
und die sind nur zwei Meter,
und gerade die Leute merken, dass es einen Baum hocken,
die vielleicht 15 Meter ist.
Und wenn man sich dem von Gurze gelöst und abstürzt,
sind 15 Meter absolut verheerend.
Darum, wichtig, wenn das passiert ist,
grundsätzlich mal Ruhe anzuseit.
Ruhe, Ruhe, Ruhe und dann sich Zeit gehen und sagen,
gut zu einer Situation analysieren.
Am Schlausten, wenn man eine Rüche zivilisierte Gegend befindet,
ist sowieso Begrätig zu informieren,
die Regalz sind von mir ein ziemlich sicheres Absturz
und die Fricht sogar schon gemeldet.
Das sind die froh, dass es wissen,
wo wir sind, ob es sich gut geht
und auch bei Hilfen benötigen.
Hilfen benötigen in meiner Ansicht,
immer dann, wenn man merkt,
ist es auf einem Baum.
Und er ist auch höher als 1-2 Meter.
Da kommt Begrätig,
die ich auch mit den Helfen und mit dem Schirm berge,
ist viel einfacher.
Also ein Sturz riskieren,
die wir gesagt haben,
höher abstürzen.
Also sprich, informieren die Leute, was los ist,
und nachher auf den Hilfen warten.
Es braucht man einen Geduld.
In unseren Gegenden haben wir ja sehr schön.
Ein paar Mal mit den Regen,
was sehr schnell sind,
und damit sprechen wir auch,
die Rettung sehr schnell eingeleitet werden.
Eine andere Landensituation,
die hofft und nicht zu er trifft,
darum ist es auch so markiert,
ist die Wasserlandung.
Wasserlandung muss man vermieden,
weil ein Stehensgewässer im Winter
kann sehr, sehr kalt werden,
und mit den Händen sich sehr schnell alleine und durch
und kann sich so unfeig machen,
so schwimmen.
Viel schlimmer ist noch in diesem Fluss.
Es ist ein Fluss-Tripp.
Da hat es ziemlich unkontrollierbar,
an man behaupten,
es kann dort,
wenn die Möglichkeit sind,
wenn ich sehen,
dass die Wasserwürde geht,
schnell vom Gurzeig aufmachen,
dass man, wenn man dann im Wasserkontakt ist,
sofort kann weg von der Ausrüstung fliegen.
Wichtig ist aber,
wenn nie bevor das Wasser berührt,
aus dem Gurzeig aussehen,
weil in den Schockmoment,
im Materialien,
wenn es sind,
haben wir nicht im Griff,
sind wir jetzt fünf Meter
über dem Wasserspiegel und gumpen,
oder sind auf 20 Meter,
und das kann auch wieder sehr starke Folgen haben,
wenn das wird falsch einschätzen.
do du die Wurst iú uwu
sür.
Du musst doch versuchen,
hier zu machen,
ob es die Zwischenzüste wir übernimmt.
Du hast noch nicht mit so viel Zeit,
zu machen,
und dannbertreuch dich an.
Das ist doch schon,
da hai ich nur an jetzt,
gab es euch zu machen,
da schau dir bei dir,
auch wenn ich dann,
was ich jetzt an den anderen Fluss,
du musst ja wieder drücken,
ja,
schau dir da,
Wenn jetzt die ganze Landingssachen nicht so funktionieren, wie nirgends werden,
oder ihr Lurgen zu, wie eine Landung nicht ganz so gemacht hat, wie ein schönes K-Hatte
und sich verletzt hätte, ist auch wichtig, also wissen wir, wie sich um ein verletzter Kümmern ist.
Wir haben beim Gleichschimpflügen ein Leider Nachteil, dass wir in den sitzenden Positionen
sind, sprich, wenn wir oben abbekommen, haben wir immer die Sitzende Position,
es geht ziemlich direkt auf die Wirbelsühle.
Darum sind auch Wirbelsühle verletzigen beim Gleichschimpflügen nicht unüblich.
Und wenn wir an den Verletzten ankommen, ist das Grund so wichtig, dass wir das auch wissen.
Das heisst, wir müssen grundsätzlich einmal beruhigen und dann merken wir relativ schnell, wie stark
oder wo ist der Pilot verletzt.
Es ist wirklich am Rücken verletzt und am Atmen funktioniert alles noch,
ist das Besten in Riegelow und unmittelbar so von den Regen zu informieren,
dass wir im Helikopter kommen und ertragen können.
Wenn der Helikopter kommt, ist es wichtig, dass er wissen, da macht es viel Wind.
Sobald er landet, das heisst, dass er ihn zusammen ist, vielleicht man verumwalten,
vielleicht euer Schirm, alles eben die E-Pakken,
das wäre mit Steijen oder E-St, damit er nichts an Wäckflügen und Helikopter auch noch gefahren hat.
Verletzigen, wenn es auf der Rücken geht, ist es also wichtig,
wenn der Pilot aufsetzen wird oder etwas trinken, ist es eine normale Reaktion,
von einem Verumfalten, den das verhindern.
Wir müssen ein Licht geblieben, nicht bewegen so langer Ansprechbar ist.
Und dann auch nicht zu trinken geht, das ist noch ein wichtiges,
nicht, ob er irgendwelche innere Verletzigen hat oder nicht.
Jetzt, jetzt können wir aufs Thema der Flugtechnik und zwar geht es darum,
dass wir auch ein bisschen wissen, was unser Schirm überhaupt kann,
oder es ist wichtig, was wir können beeinflussen,
dass er bei den Schirm etwas besser geleitet oder weniger sinkt.
Und da ist es auch ganz einfach, auf dieser Skala ersichtlich,
dass wenn wir sagen, wir werden bei einem Schuelschirm,
uns das beste gleiten, das heisst, wir kommen von Punkt A nach Punkt B am Witte,
dass wir unser Bremsen ungefähr auf 5-15 cm Kontakt haben,
bei dieser Geschheit, wo wir das Ganze möglichst lange in der Luft bleiben,
also das geringste, sinken in der Halle.
Dann kommen wir zwar nicht am Witte,
das sind aber vor der Zeit, am längsten in der Luft.
Ein bisschen mehr Bremsen, nämlich schon 15-10 km,
ich habe ein bisschen mehr als Trimspeid.
Und weil wir minimal fährt, also das,
wo der Gleichschirm Garten noch fliegen mag,
bevor er richtig sangflug,
wenn wir später dazu kommen, geht,
minimal fahrt sie immer der relativ starke Bremsen,
da können wir den Schor richtig heften,
aber wichtig, aber die Dellbogen schauen immer noch schön nach.
Aber und dann sind wir da etwa bei 40 cm,
wo wir schon relativ im langen Bereich fliegen.
Das Gegenteil kann wir auch machen,
nämlich Beschleunigen,
wenn wir unser Fussbeschleunigen,
oder der meiste Leute der Fall ist,
können durchdrehten,
dann holen wir viel Geschwindigkeit wieder an,
weil wir nichts anderes machen,
also unser Anstellwinkel verglindern,
um wir werden schneller,
und so fliegt auch das Schirm dünnlich schneller.
Der Beschleunigen braucht man ganz einfach gesagt,
immer dennen, wenn wir gegen Wind haben.
Also grundsätzlich,
wir werden dann auch von der Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen-Bremsen
die Schilder der Vortage in der Landenplatz,
oder wo wir immer noch einen anderen Fliegen noch erreichen können.
Dann gibt es ja nicht nur das Fliegen an für sich mit Start und Landen.
Wir haben es jetzt schon besprochen, sondern es soll auch Spaß machen.
Es gibt auch so genannte Sohring.
Wenn man einen Tankaufwind nutzen kann,
dann redet man eigentlich von Sohring,
wenn das ein überregionales Wind ist,
wo der Hang aufströmt.
Jetzt gibt es ein Aufwindband.
Und in dem Aufwindband kann man unsere höhere Palten
ausstiegern.
Und das nicht mehr so.
Das ist meistens nur ein Wind bedingt.
Es gibt auch Thermistin,
weil noch ein bisschen viel Mist ist mit Thermik.
Da redet man jetzt mal vom Sohrer.
Dort ist es wichtig,
kann als Anfang der Landabstand,
der Landabstand,
und noch mal der Landabstand.
Warum?
Weil wir sind ja die ganze Zeit am Glend.
Es gibt vielleicht noch andere Flugteinnehmer,
wo auch die Fliegenwände
und die Beizle-Turbe-Lenzen verursachen,
durch ihre Flugräte.
Und wenn man diesen Fliegen
schnell mal umgewertet hat,
oder es kann natürlich auch mehr Wind gehen,
und es treibt sich auch mehr Richtighangen,
da man man auch nicht mehr zu reagieren,
dass man wieder vom Hang wegfliegen kann.
Und allgemein immer Kurven weg vom Hang drehen.
Nicht zum Hang an,
da haben wir Rückgewinnkomponente im Hand.
Sinkgewinnkomponente von der Kurvenselber
ist nicht abschätzbar.
Und wenn man mit Rückenwände so richtig hangt,
dann ist es nicht gut.
Also die Sachen, die am Sohring
immer ganz fest beachten.
Jetzt haben wir
je nachgebiert
natürlich aus Thermiflügen drin.
Und das Thermiflügen
ist ja das,
wo wahrscheinlich so eine Königsticeblein ist
beim Gleichschumfliegen.
Wir werden ja möglichst weit fliegen.
Das heisst, wir werden Thermik nutzen
als Transporter.
Weil wenn man nur Fliegen drüber gelaufen hat,
dann haben wir auch Flüssig Leidleistung.
Wenn man z.B. von 1.000 Meter startet,
dann können wir 8 Kilometer weit beruhigen.
Jetzt haben wir aber Thermik.
Das heisst,
dann muss ich auch in Bescheid wissen,
wie ich diese Thermik behauptet,
und wenn ich die auch fliegen,
das Thermik fliegen.
Damit ich kann Thermik fliegen,
muss ich auch ein paar Grundregeln wissen.
Am Eifachstisch, natürlich,
wenn wir die Visuel Kontrolle haben vor den Wolken,
dann sehen wir die Thermik optisch.
Stütten wir einfach so zum Fliegen.
Wir nehmen jetzt ein Beispiel für den Wolken.
Wenn wir kein Wind haben,
ist es relativ einfach,
den Schluch zu finden,
den Fliegen einfach geraten und die Wolken.
Und haben den Schluch relativ schnell gefunden,
hoffen und ganz stiegen.
Das Ganze will ich schwierig, wenn wir Wind haben.
Wir nehmen jetzt hier ein Beispiel,
das der Wind von links kommt.
Die Wolken wird also so abtreiben.
Das heisst,
mit dem Schirm muss ich jetzt in die Luftseite
von den Wolken fliegen,
damit dich schön im Schluch
mit dem Windversatz zusammenstiegen kann.
Und so optimal ist Thermik verwirrt.
Das Ganze ist relativ einfach im Flachland aussehen,
auch gut zu jedem Schwierigen,
wie es wenn man den richtigen Bergen
richtig zum Bergen steilwand hat,
weil der Thermik sehr knackig,
sehr löst, sehr schnell ab.
Das heisst,
es ist nicht großflächig,
sondern klifrechig,
und dementsprechend auch eher turbulent.
Das ist zwar gut,
wenn man sehr schnell,
sehr englige Kreis und Stiegen,
aber für den Anfangern
führt das sehr rasch zur Überforderung.
Wichtig ist in der Thermik,
dass man schön locker sitzt,
dass man viel mit Gewichtsverlagung schafft.
Mit einerseits
Thermik schön austrayen,
aber auch ganz fest,
wenn man einen Gewicht schafft,
viel Piloten,
man kann das viel zu wenig,
dann fest über Premse schafft,
und zwar wenig mit Gewichtsverlagung.
Ganz wichtig,
wenn man sicher ist,
dass man den Nächspunkt,
die man vorgegangen hat,
will bestimmen, auch erreicht.
Das ist nichts,
wenn man Thermik reißt und das Frühlos geht,
und dann gar nicht am nächsten Bergen
blachen,
wo man die Nächsteermik erwartet.
Sondern es ist wirklich wichtig,
dass man Thermik ausdreht,
und dadurch das viel geduld,
dass man Töche dann hat,
was man sicher zu dem nächsten Plan
der Punkt ankommt,
wo man davon ausgeht,
dass die Nächstetermik
wieder stattfindet,
wieder ein Haufen befördert.
Das Ganze braucht natürlich extrem viel Erfahrung,
und am Anfang zufrieden sein,
wenn man im Flachland,
Thermikadreien,
schön gemütlich stiegen hat,
dass geniessen,
dann kommt auch der Erfolg mit einer Erfahrung.
Beim Thermikflügen,
können wir auch,
irgendeinig zu Situationen,
wo man vielleicht nicht umbringt,
sprich aus einem Schirmflug,
wie wir nicht gewöhnt sind.
Da können Sie den Klappen dazu,
da können Sie den Frontklappen dazu,
was wir jetzt im Thema Türen nehmen.
Entschuldigung.
Türen nehmen,
ist die Flugmanöfer.
Wenn man beim Schweizerischen Hängegläten
verbandert,
dann können wir auch die Prieffixmanöfer
relevanten,
die Wunderschönen,
als Video erklärt,
weil auch der Prieffig,
wenn man gewisse Manöfer von denen
können, fliegen.
Wir füllen da in den kleinen Orten,
da haben wir vorhin schon mal gehört
bei der Landung.
Die kleine Orten sind nichts anderes,
die österreichische Anleihen,
von jedem Seher,
es ist die österreichische Anleihen,
nicht zu verwechseln mit den Stabilaleinen.
Stabilaleinen ist die auf der österreichischen
Punktengleichschirmflug,
meistens farblich,
der Trend und sehr dünn.
Wir haben aber die österreichische Anleihen,
die wir brauchen zum Schirmaufzimmer.
Die ist zum Teil bei gewissen
Kleidschirmmodell Trend, zum Teil auch zusammen.
Es ist auch immer die österreichische Körme
links und rechts,
und dann unsere kleine Orteiklappen.
Wir palten die Donung und können wunderbar
üben mit Gewichtverlagung
die Schämen trotzdem noch stüren.
Die kleinen Orten sind wie schon gesagt,
z.B. wenn man eine höchige Landung hat
und ein bisschen schneller abwenden,
supermanöfer,
oder wenn man einfach mehr Sinkern
generieren kann,
zum Schämen kennenlernen,
kleine Orte zu machen,
absolut gut zu manöfer,
das sieben.
Es gibt auch grosse Orten,
dann nimmt man je nach Schirmmodellen,
nicht nur die österreichische Anleihen,
sondern die zweitösterreichische Anleihen,
wenn man drüben hat.
Und dann können wir viel mehr Orten innen.
Ganz wichtig, da gibt es auch Schämen,
die nur zwei Aufhänkungen haben.
Und da darf man die beiden innen
schon machen,
man kann im Frontklapper.
Dann gehen wir nichts anderes,
als kleine Orte sogeriefen
und für grossen Jahre,
dann haben wir unsere Hand von innen her
und dann abknicken,
da haben wir rund 15, 20 Ante mehr Leinen,
und nehmen sie dann innen.
Für grossen Jahre.
Ganz wichtig bei den grossen Orten,
die gleichzeitig zu diesem Prozess
von der Leinen innen holen,
beschleunigen.
Weil nur so,
können wir verhindern,
dass wir zu viel Orten machen,
zu viel wieder standen,
das Schirm langsam flügt
und dann richtig sagflug gut.
In dem, dass wir beschleunigen,
dann drücken, holen wir davon,
und die jetzt kannten wir wieder,
aber und das Schirm ist wieder
im normalen Winkel am Flügen,
trotz dem grossen wiederstand,
die die Orten machen.
Nachher zum Tor und aufmachen,
einfach loslaufen.
Erst wenn die Orten komplett offen sind,
dann aus dem Beschleunigen rausgehen.
Auch da wieder,
würden wir die Orten innen holen,
lassen sie los und gehen,
geht aus dem Beschleunigen raus,
haben wir immer noch viel wieder standen,
und das Schirm flügt langsam
und durch die Beschleunigen rausgehen,
kann sie,
dass wir dann gerade richtig sagflug sind,
dann kommen,
und das wollen wir verhindern.
Sagflug ist schon nichts anderes,
als wir das langsam flügt.
Unsere Schirmseite, die Flüge,
es hat die Vorwärtsfahrt,
haben wir das mal unterschritten.
Da geht es bevor,
quasi nach hinten kiebt,
und komplett läuft,
entlebt aus dem Schirm.
Da gibt es ein Vorstufe,
das sagflug,
das Schirm ist zwar noch gefüllt.
Wir haben keine Vorwärtsfahrt mehr,
und wir haben nur noch Sinken
und spüren das aus dem Schirm,
dass da keine Vorwärtsfahrt mehr ist,
es fühlt sich komisch an.
Das Schirm ist schwammig,
dann sind wir langsam gelogen,
haben die Bremse jetzt wieder da.
Oder bei ganz nassem Schirm gelogen,
kann auch sein,
dass wir dann in den Sagflug kommen.
Dann ist das Grundsätzlich wichtig,
wir sind es langsam gelogen,
was ist,
die Teile von langsam schnell,
also wenn wir schnell werden.
Das heisst,
sofort hat A,
Dragurten und drücken,
damit die Speed macht,
oder auch die Beschleunigen,
wie es die Wurzeit,
das ganze Beschleunigen,
wir würden dann auch wieder
in normalen Positionen kriegen,
damit wir wieder fahrt auf den Indem
und aus dem Sagflug aus sich kommen.
Was auch gegeben hat,
im Termik fliegen,
dass wir immer fliegen,
wir verbütchen den Windschärik
und packen das Schirm
bis 50 % drin.
Völlig aus dem Neutusen.
Wir schreiten uns erst einmal.
Es ist normal am Anfang,
aber auch da,
es ist wichtig,
dass wir hier reagieren und münd reagieren.
Wenn wir nichts machen,
macht es dahin,
der Schirm nach dem Klappen
wieder extrem viel wieder standen.
Und dann will auf die Seite
der Dreie,
wo der Klappen passiert.
Hier mit Tonen Hangen
kommt es relativ schnell nicht gut.
Darum ist es wichtig,
dass wir so viel reagieren.
Klappen drin oder Tonen
ist auch egal.
Wenn Klappen passiert,
muss es unser Grundsatz sein.
So viel Gewicht aufgegeben,
leicht abremsen mit den Gägen.
Bremsen, wenn es nötig ist,
damit wir mal gerade ausführen können
und da wieder Grundsatz zu zerstabilisieren
und dann reagieren.
Dann kann wir uns um den Klappen
beschäftigen, zum da wieder öffnen.
Wenn wir
möglichst Absteig Hilfe machen,
sprich,
machen wir schnell,
weil wir z.B.
das Gewicht in die Mama schendet.
Wir sagen,
wir werden nicht so lange gelaufen,
die über das Gewicht dabei ist.
Da kann sie,
dass es Sinn macht,
gewisse Absteigemannüfe zu beherrschen.
Die grossen Orten,
die wir vorbegesprochen haben,
das ist ganz wichtig
und gute Absteigemannüfe,
wie mit den grossen Orten,
kann man den Gewicht
noch stürren und voranfliegen.
Also sprich,
weil wir einen starken Aufwindband sind.
Flüge man weg von den Aufwindband.
Und bleiben nicht nach drinnen.
Der Bestal,
wo du auch beschrieben wird
und dass der Brief gefragt wird,
da hat der grossen Nachteil,
dass wir hier zu machen,
und weil wir viel Sinken generieren,
wir aber die Orten stellen,
aber wir können,
sprich,
wenn wir im Aufwindband sind,
im Starchen,
immer noch drinnen sind.
Und auch gleich,
dann fliegen wir.
Bestal ist nicht anders,
dass wir wieder nahmen,
seit uns an,
nicht an,
sondern an B-Drag,
die B-Drag,
dann langsam zu uns anziehen.
Wichtig ist,
dass wir bremse,
ganz normal in der Hand haben,
nicht wirklich gewickelt,
indem wir die gleichzeitig auch noch abziehen.
Sondern das ist mir...
B-Drag,
die B-Drag,
die B- das so abziehen.
Und dann gibt es da im Untersegel in Fals,
und in Märkern, die haben zu nur noch Sinken.
Und da kann man gut in den Basis kunden,
halte,
bei mir eine Training
oder auch unter Begleitung von Fluglehrer am Funkt.
Haben wir das gut mal lieben.
Nachher,
der Bestal wieder löse,
ist nicht anders,
als der Anfangsbereich
langsam,
und dann ganz,
auf den Vier,
und auch auf den Vier,
und auf den Vier,
und dann gibt es 4.000 Kilo.
Und das verdreht nicht jeder.
Und darum ist es wichtig,
da ein super Training zu machen,
an einer Sicher,
eine Sicherheitskursunteraleitung,
oder es gibt auch die Chance
vom G-Force Trainer,
der das Wunderbar,
an einer Simulator,
kann ich eben
und dich kennenlernen,
wie du reagierst,
bei Steispirale.
Geschichten.
Der Neues-Manöfer,
das kommt jetzt in die Tourifrog-Need,
ist aber noch ganz schön zu erwähnen,
ist,
dass man quasi Steispirale macht,
mit einem Klappenkalt.
Das ist zuerst,
wenn man es schon besprochen hat.
Und dann macht man,
auf der Gegenseite,
der Woffern ist noch ein Spirale.
Das hat ein Vorteil,
dass man viel Synke generiert,
aber wenig G-Kräfte haben.
Das sind wir wieder in die G-Kräfte
und ein Geforken darstellen.
Ist auch ein Manösen,
wo ein Seiko gehört,
aber wichtig,
dass es schon mal gehört hat.
Was für eine Theorie-Test kommt,
ist deine Frille,
die Wiste,
wie ein Ober- und Licken.
Und damit wissen,
was das ist.
Frille ist nicht anders,
als jetzt heim einseiten,
zu viellaben zu sagen.
Zum Beispiel,
eben auch ein Spiral-Weliland,
da haben es aber völlig gerotmotorisch gemacht.
Und dann geht die Heimzeit weg
und die Schimmdreite negativ.
Das ist frill.
Wenn man das sehr schnell machen kann,
kann sie,
dass der Schirm obendreit,
und wir unten,
haben das Momentum,
wo im Schirm zuerst mal mit dem Folgen zu wenig Schnee sind.
Ich kann sie aus der Schirmschule reiten
und mir befinden,
dieser Position von Anfang an.
Und dann kann ich vorstellen,
da sind diese Drahtbote,
gibt es ganz schnell,
macht das Schirm etwas Back.
Und jetzt habe ich ein Twist.
Das heißt,
nichts anderes,
als der Draht gut grützt sind.
Dann bin ich im Twist.
Das ist die Begriffe dafür.
Wenn ich...
Wingen wir wie Flüge?
Ist nichts anderes,
dass ich das Schirm zum Rollen bringen kann?
Es heißt,
ich entscheide mich,
freie Seite,
links und rechts,
mach es Gewicht und Bremseinsatz auf die Seite.
Und sobald ich wieder
unten in den Pendeln
gebe ich bereits auf Gegenseiten,
die Bremsein-Pause.
Unzureichtbar!
Wo das Gold und Spezler
aussieht und später auch mit der Bremsein-Pause.
Da einfach die Bremsein-Pause in Döden
geschieht.
Da kommen diese Bremsein-Pause an der Bremsein-Pause.
Da kommen die Bremsein-Pause an der Bremsein-Pause.
Da kommen die certain Bremsein-Pause.
Da kommen die
Leute,
die die Leute, die Leute, die Leute, die Leute, die Leute.
Augenstünde, sie bemerkt einfach,
Man darf zum Schämen kennenlernen und trainieren.
Das Gleiche ist nicht, es ist nicht anders,
dass wir die Schämen stehen stark abremsen.
Schämen geht hinteren.
Mehr als Person für uns, und jetzt warten wir,
bis die Schämen wieder für hundern.
Vorschüßt, warten bis im Unterdürbhängen.
Jetzt wollen wir wieder bremsen.
Dort ist meistens höfige Gefahr, dass die Leute schon
beim Abbesenken wieder im Bremsen,
das so die Schämen stoppen,
sondern wenn wir wirklich warten im Unterdürbhängen,
bis am unterste Punkt ein bisschen drüber sind,
und dann wieder bremsen.
Das ist nicht so ein Weg, die wir bekommen.
Dort wollen sie der Prieffix sehen,
dass sie bis zur Austritts- und eintrittskanten pendelt.
Es ist nicht der Wahnsinnigsteig, aber doch,
wir müssen am Schämen schaffen,
und das ist ein Ziel,
daran, dass wir das Ganze kennenlernen können.
Jetzt den Freeläuten,
wie ihr Wing-Augur und Licken,
das kann alles viel Spaß machen
und macht absolut Sinn,
um zu trainieren.
Jetzt kann es ja aber auch immer sein,
dass das Ganze in den Hosen gut ist.
Und das Thema Rettungssystem,
das nächste Kapitel ist zum Zukunft,
immer und ich,
man wusste sie,
eure Rettungssystem nicht zu tun.
Das ist absolut für die Katze- und Rettungssysteme.
Wenn ihr es nicht zieht,
und das ganz, ganz, wichtige Grundsatz,
die Fahrschirmspringen haben das System,
das, wenn sie eine gewisse Zeit,
eine gewisse Höhe beschreiten haben,
automatische Rettung zieht.
Mehr Glätschenblüge haben das nicht
und konstruktionen bedingt,
hat es auch noch nie einen geschaffenen Lösungsfonds finden.
Das heisst,
ihre Notsituation münd mehr als Pilot,
akte den Notschämen zieht.
Und nur wenn man nicht zieht,
aktee funktioniert auch.
Dann müssen wir ganz fest nicht bewusst sein.
Wenn wir die Situation haben,
Autofkontrol,
und wir machen nicht,
wie sich die Situation nicht verbessern.
Sie tun zuerst den Verbessern,
wenn man sagen, jetzt ist es nicht gut.
Jetzt kann ich Autofkontrol,
jetzt muss ich mein Schirm
gehen und ziehe.
Wenn du einen Schirm ziehst,
die Grundsatz,
ist immer den, wenn es unkontrierbar ist.
Sprich ich einen Zustand,
wo ich nicht weiss, wo oben, wo unten ist,
und der Zustand,
du jetzt nicht innerhalb von kürzester Zeit,
da werden wir drei Sekunden,
zwei Rüse-Kunden stabilisieren,
und wie die Normalflug geht,
ist die Zeit für Notschirmen.
Ich habe das Ganze wenig höchig,
sprich ich beim Abbaugum,
im Landenbereich,
und ja, es ist wenig höchig.
Und ich habe das Problem.
Sofot der Notschirm ziehe.
Autofkontrol,
ich wüsse nicht, was der Schirm macht,
sofot der Notschirm ziehe.
Das kann aus einem Klappraus, zum Beispiel passieren.
Es kann passieren, dass es zwei Sprems haben,
wenn wir vorgesehen haben frillenbasiert,
etwas unkontaliert, gleich Notschirmen.
Das kann aber auch sein,
dass es zusammen ist,
weil es wieder läuft.
Wir haben zwar relativ viel Platz wieder Luft,
aber doch andere Luftfahrteinnehmer,
und wenn wir einen Zusammenstoß haben,
dann ist es sicherer aus der Zeit,
für den Notschirm ziehe.
Wir wissen, nämlich selbst,
wenn wir den Zusammenstoß gehen und wieder fliegen,
wissen wir, dass das Fluggerät so stark beschädigt,
dass vielleicht genau den Erschmerkern,
wenn wir im Landenabflug sind,
sprich nicht,
können reagieren und den Notschirm ziehe.
Darum zusammenstoß,
wenn wir noch eine Flüge
über einen grossen Saltflügen Notschirm ziehe,
wenn er schon auf Kontrolle ist,
kommt wieder das Erste zum Grundsatz.
Das hat es zum E-Bedenken und den Notschirm so viel zu ziehen.
Es kann auch sein,
dass es eine Medizinis-Problem hat.
Ihr Flüge hat aus,
und es wird die Schwarz-Veraugen.
Egal, wie es nicht okay sieht.
Denn dann ist der Notschirm die besten Varianten,
also irgendwo umechtig,
in das Kländinnen zu fliegen,
mit dem Gleichschirm.
Keine gute Option.
Was auch für Zutage sehr wenig
vorkommt, bis gar nicht mehr vorkommt,
ist Materialbruch,
aber es könnte ja mal sein,
dass es eben Dachvorkommt.
Im E-Bedenken am Gurt-Züge ist etwas so,
etwas Nümsäten,
und die haben der Flug beendet,
das man kommt
schrägen kann,
weil etwas grissen ist,
dann ist es sicher aus dem Thema
für den Notschirm.
Der Grundsatz
von der zweiten Chancen,
wenn man unkontrolliert ist,
dass man die zweite Chancen
der Notschirm nicht sieht,
ist ganz, ganz wichtig,
für die ganze Flügelreihe.
Ich sage bei dem,
wo es zweite Chancen,
wenn man die Hand
und Münd wissen,
wie es funktioniert,
das ganze System.
Wie das funktioniert,
müssen wir unbedingt durch die Flugsschule
noch fragen,
ich möchte,
dass der Nieren in der Zürich,
dass er wissen,
wo der Notschirmgriff ist,
eine gute E-Bike dazu ist,
z.B. auch,
wenn er mein normales Flug ausgelügt
mit der Flache Hand bei jedem Flug,
wo er tauscht,
wo ich ein Notschirm ist,
dass er im Notfall
den auch wissen,
wie zu reagieren.
Der Notschirm ist ein grosser Bereich.
Da gehören noch Sachen dazu,
wie man nun ein Packen will.
Das z.B. der Hersteller
sagt,
auch 6 Mündetfrischpacken.
Braxis zeigt,
6 Mündet bis im Jahr.
Alles andere sieht man den Wüknit machen,
länger als das Jahr verpackt,
sondern könnte er neu gefalten.
Das ist ein grosses Thema
und ein Kurs für sich.
Was wir hier besprochen haben,
der Flug Braxis,
ist das,
wo er an der Priefik gefrögt wird,
er mir kennen,
und ich hoffe,
ich hat den Vortrag gefallen.
Ich bedanke mich ganz fest
für ihre Aufmerksamkeit
und bis bald.